everything we've discussed so far
involved recognizing and tagging or
engulfing shady things that were found
outside of cells so outside of cells
we've seen things like a B cell a B cell
has its membrane membrane bound
antibodies its membrane bound antibodies
maybe one of these might might recognize
something shady out in the outside of
the cell and of course this part over
here as we know these they all have a
variable portion right over here so this
is specific to this shady thing then
this will be engulfed and then parts of
it parts of it will be attached to an
MHC 2 complex so let me do that in a
different color so an MHC 2 complex and
then that will go to the surface that
will go to the membrane of the cell to
present itself so that's an MH 2 MHC 2
complex and so it has a little bit of
the little little piece of this shady
thing out here and we call this little
shady peach this is an antigen this is
an antigen presenting cell here and then
we've seen is especially if this is a
b-cell then a helper T cell that also
has a variable portion that corresponds
to that corresponds to this specific
antigen so this would be a helper T cell
right over here so this is a helper T
helper cell when it recognizes then
it'll start dividing into memory helper
T cells and effect our helper T cell so
the effector helper T cells essentially
ring the alarm bells and start kind of
accelerating the B cell replication I
guess you could say that the B cell
activation and and the theory is that
this is kind of a double handshake
process but once again this is what's
occurring outside of cells so when we
found stuff outside of cells we engulf
them and then we presented them on MHC 2
complexes
mhm see two complexes so now you're
probably thinking well yeah I mean
that's the outside of cells but you know
there's MHC - there's these helper T
cells but we've also referred to
cytotoxic T cells what do those do and
we've also if there's MHC - there's
probably an MHC one complex what does
the MHC one complex do and if we're you
know we can recognize shady things that
are happening outside of cells but don't
shady things sometimes happen inside
cells and what do we how does our immune
system respond to that and actually as
you can imagine all of those all of
those things will be answered in the
rest of this video so let's think about
what's happening let's think about what
happens when shady things start to
happen inside a cell so for example for
example it might not even be due to a
virus or due to way back to some type of
bacteria it could be the cell itself has
gone awry so let's say that this right
over here is a cancer cell so it's had
some mutations it's starting to multiply
like crazy so this is a cancer cell and
the cancer cell because it had mutation
it's going to produce it's going to
produce some weird some weird proteins
so these cancer cells are going to
produce some weird proteins so every
every every cell with a nucleus in your
body and that's pretty much every cell
except for red blood cells has the has
MHC one complexes and the point the
whole point of the MHC one complex is to
but is to bind to shady things that are
produced inside of the cell shady things
that are produced inside of the cell and
then present them to the membrane so
even a malfunctioning cancer cell should
be doing this so then it will so this
MHC one complex is bound to this two
bound to this these strange proteins
that are produced by the the mutations
inside of the nucleus and then it can
present them and then it can present
them and so what you could imagine what
the appropriate immune spot response
should be these things these cancer
cells these cancerous
cells should be killed and actually let
me label this properly so that was MHC 2
you're presenting an antigen that was
found that was initially found outside
of the cells engulf with and taken out
MHC 1 MHC 1 it's binding to shady things
inside the cell and then presenting it
out now this thing should be killed
now as you can imagine what's going to
kill it well that's where the cytotoxic
T cell comes into the picture so the
cytotoxic T cell is going to have so
that's a receptor right there it'll have
a variable portion that's specific to
this type of an antigen and so it'll
bind there and then once it does that it
says oh boy there's just all this shady
stuff here these shady proteins that are
in produce this this cell and all the
other ones like it need to be killed
and so the cytotoxic T cell will begin
to replicate once again like other other
types of immune cells it's going to
replicate into the into the memory cells
just in case this type of thing shows up
ten years in the future and also the
effector cells so this is memory and
also effector and also and also affect
your cells effector cytotoxic T cells
and as we always know the effector
version is the thing that actually does
something it starts to actually affect
things and what it is going to affect it
is going to start binding to things that
are that are presenting the same antigen
on top of as part of their M R on top of
their MHC one complex so this character
right over here so it's presenting that
same antigen it's presenting that same
antigen on this MHC one complex and
remember the variable portions need to
match up so let's say that this is this
is an effector cytotoxic T cell an
effector cytotoxic T cell and actually
let me draw it a little bit a little bit
different
so let me draw it like this this is
effector cytotoxic T cell its receptor
it's variable portion is the one that's
compatible with this antigen that's
being presented right over here so let
me just label this again this is the
MHC one complex this is an effector
cytotoxic cytotoxic T cell so I put the
C there for cytotoxic and what it does
is essentially kind of latches on to the
cell that needs to die and it does it it
not only just has this receptor
interfacing with the MHC one complex but
it actually has a whole series of
protein and I'm proteins and I'm not
drawing this to scale really this would
be much smaller relative to the scale of
cell that essentially latches on between
the two and I'm not going to go into
detail but essentially forms what you
could call an immuno synapse which is
kind of where the two things are
interacting with each other and so when
it identifies this and says okay I need
to kill this thing or essentially I need
to make this thing kill itself it starts
releasing all of these molecules so it
can release molecules like perforins so
it'll release these perforins
which will essentially cause gaps or
holes to follow to fit to form in the in
the in the membrane of the cell that
needs to die and it could release other
things like granzymes that can go in and
essentially cause this thing to kill
itself so the whole point of this video
is to appreciate I guess what we haven't
talked about yet we had already talked
about what happens when you identify
shady things outside of the cells and
then how you can kind of bring them in
and then present them and then use that
to can further activate the immune
response
now we're talking about identifying
shady things inside the cell those get
presented by MHC one complexes and then
the cytotoxic T cells recognize them and
then force the cell to kill themselves
and this wouldn't just be cancer cells
this could also apply to a cell that has
already been infected by a virus so for
example a cell like this already so
that's its nucleus it's already been
infected by some virus it's already been
infected by some virus so it's hide the
virus has hijacked the cells
replication machinery in order to
replicate itself and so the proper
immune response is hey look I'm uh I'm
uh
I'm a virus making machine I I should
kill myself so so it'll take some Italy
antigens that are being produced inside
of by virtue of by the fire
is there going to bind to MHC one
complex --is to MHC one complex is so
pieces of the virus we're going to bind
to MHC one complex is and then they're
going to be presented on the surface
they're going to be presented we do it
this way presented on on the surface so
this exact process can happen again